[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليالي الاختيار استهلها بابرز
الاعمى
مصيره مجهول ينتظر اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
موسكو ترفض التنازل وجوتيرج يدعو لتمديد
الصفقه
عقوبات امريكيه على مسؤولين كبيرين في
السجون الايرانيه الانتهاكهم حقوق الانسان
مصادر غربيه للعربيه غارت دير الزور
استهدفت اسلحه ايرانيه ونفذتها امريكا
بالتنسيق مع اسرائيل
تداعيات الزلزال تهدد شعبيات اردوغان في
الانتخابات وناجون يقولون بان المعارضه
ليست بافضل
[موسيقى]
البدايه مشاهدينا من ملف تصدير الحبوب
والاتفاق بين روسيا واوكرانيا الذي بات
مصيره مجهولا مع اصرار الروسي على عدم
التنازل عن شروطها وعلى راسها تفتيش كل
السفن الى جانب التعند الاوكراني في ذات
السياق مصدر تركي دبلوماسي اكد ان كياف
رفضت مطالب موسكو الا انه ورغم ذلك
فالمفاوضات لم تنتهي بعد بدوره وخلال
زيارته لكي افدعى الامير العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو غوترج كل منزلنسكي وبوتين
دعاهما الى تمديد اتفاقيات صفقه الحبوب
محذرا من عواقب وخيمه قد تضر بامن الغذاء
العالمي
اود التاكيد على اهميه تمديد اتفاق الحبوب
بعد الثامنه عشر من مارسا الحالي واهميه
العمل على تهيئه الظروف لاقصى استخدام
ممكن للبنيه التحتيه للتصدير عبر البحر
الاسود وفقا لاهداف المبادره
هذا كان سياسيا اما ميدانيا تعاني قوات
فاغنر على الخطوط الاماميه من نقص الذخيره
هذا وما اكده قائد القوات قوات فاجنر اذا
اشتكى اكثر من مره من نقص الذخيره التي
تصل لقواتها واظهر فيديو نشر لقائد قوات
فاجنر الروسيه اثناء حديثه مع احد
المقاتلين على الخطوط الاماميه وهو يتحدث
عن نقص الذخيره وعن المساعدات التي تصل
للقوات على الارض
مسعود
او فرم اللحم كما وصفت تكلفاتها باهظه على
الجيش الروسي وتفوق خسائر اوكرانيا باشواط
وفق حلف شمال الاطلسي حيث اكد خساره روسيا
ما يقدر بخمسه رجال مقابل كل جندي
اوكرانيا في معركه باخموت كما نقلت صحيفه
ديليله وفي هذا الاطار رجح المتحدث باسم
مجموعه القوات الشرقيه في اوكرانيا ان
تكون معركه باخمت هي الاخيره لقوات فاكنين
واوضح
تنفذ من المقاتلين المجندين من السجون
الذين رميوا على الخطوط الاماميه في
[موسيقى]
قال الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسيا
ستارتنبرغ انه لا يستبعد سقوط باخ مدخله
لايام مشيرا الى ضروره عدم انعكاس ذلك على
وتحوله الى نقطه تحول في الحرب تناول
الاخيره نرى قتالا شرسا في باخموت روسيا
تلقي بالمزيد من القوات وما تفتقده من
المهارات العسكريه تعوضه بكميات القوات
عانوا من خسائر كبيره ولكن في الوقت نفسه
لا يمكن استبعاد ان بخموت ستسقط في
النهايه خلال الايام المقبله لذا من المهم
ان لا ينعكس ذلك الى نقطه تحول في الحرب
وهو ايضا يؤكد ضروره عدم الاستهانه بروسيا
حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه حذيفه يعني
اعاده الحديث عن موضوع اتفاقيات الحبوب
والتعمد من قبل الجانبين بالشروط ما هي
الاصداء هناك
وهل هناك من مخرج بهذا الموضوع
نعم مساء الخير ليال هذا هو الموضوع
الرئيسي الذي تم نقاشه اليوم في هذه
المباحثات التي جرت ما بين الرئيس
فلاديمير زيليسكي وما بين الامين العام
للامم المتحده انطونيو ووفدي المرافق
المباحثات تطرقت الى عده نقاط ولكن النقطه
الاهميه كانت مساله تصدير الحبوب على
العكس تماما يعني الجانب الاوكراني يؤكد
على اهميه تمديد هذه الاتفاقيه ولكن طبعا
هنالك بعض التعقيدات التي تاتي كما يقول
الجانب الاوكراني من قبل الاتحاد الروسي
في تاخير عمليات التصدير وعمليات التفتيش
ايضا في سواء كان في البحر في عرض البحر
او في الموانئ التركيه لذلك هنالك بعض
الملاحظات من الجانب الاوكراني ولكنها
تطالب بتمديد هذه الاتفاقيه وتقول ان هذه
الاتفاقيه ضروريه جدا الجانب الاوكراني
يتحدث عن عائدات من صادرات الحبوب حوالي
200 مليون دولار فقط في الفتره الماضيه
كما ان
اوكرانيا استطاعت ان ترسل الحبوب الى عده
دول خاصه تلك الدول الناميه والتي تعاني
في الغذاء كذلك
اكد على ضروره تمديد هذه الاتفاقيه واكد
على المساعي التي التي ستبذل من قبلهم مع
الجانب الروسي لتمديد هذه الاتفاقيه
الجانب الروسي لديه شروط صعبه جدا كما
وصفها الجانب الاوكراني ولكن يتوقع ان يصل
الجانبان الى اتفاق في ذلك في هذا الامر
خاصه ان الاتحاد الروسي على الرغم من
تعنته كما يقول الاوكرانيون الا انه في في
النهايه فلا بد ان يخضع لتمديد هذه
الاتفاقيه لان الامر لا يتعلق فقط
باوكرانيا ولا روسيا هو يتعلق بالامن
الغذائي العالمي وايضا
لروسيا حلفاء يستفيدون من هذه الاتفاقيه
لذلك في النهايه سوف يتم الاتفاق لكن كيف
سيتم الاتفاق ومتى سيتم الاتفاق هذا الامر
حتى الان ايضا نظر وقيدا النقاش شكرا لك
حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه حدثتنا منك
نبقى في اوكرانيا منعو سقوط اوكرانيا
وصمود جيشها حتى الان امام ثاني اكبر جيوش
العالم اثار استغراب الكثيرين غير ان
الفضل بهذا الصمود يعود لثلاثه قاده
عسكريين يقومون بادوار في ساحات المعارك
لا تقل عن دور زيلينسكي لكنهم كل البعد عن
الاعلام الجنرال الجنرالات الثلاثه الذين
ساهموا في منع سقوط اوكرانيا ينتمون الى
حقبه ما بعد الاتحاد السوفيتي ومسلحين
بثقافه الناتو بحسب تقرير لصحيفه لموض
الفرنسيه هؤلاء القاده المحوريين وفق
الصحيفه الفرنسيه لم يرتكبوا خطا
الاستخفاف بعدوهم وبنفس الوقت لم يبالغوا
بتقدير قوه الجيش الروسي اولهم فاليري
زالوشني القائد الاعلى للقوات الاوكرانيه
الذي يوصف بالرجل الحديدي
[موسيقى]
اما ثاني القاده فهو قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه الجنرال
بنقل جميع مراكز القياده الى الميدان
باتجاه المحاور المحتمله للتقدم الروسي
قبل نحو اسبوع من بدء العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه كما اصدر امرا بنقل الاصول الجويه
للجيش الاوكراني بما في ذلك المروحيات
والطائرات النفاثه من القواعد الرئيسيه
وذلك ابعدها بشكل كبير عن اهداف الغارات
الجويه الواضحه نظم ايضا حلقتين من القوات
لحمايه كياف احداهما في الضواحي الخارجيه
للعاصمه ومنها داخل العاصمه
[موسيقى]
فيما ثالث الجنرالات الاوكرانيين مشاهدينا
والذي كان بمثابه الدعامه للقوات
الاوكرانيه فهو كاريلو بودان اوف قائد
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه حارب ضد
القوات الروسيه بالوكاله في الحرب التي
اندلعت شرطي اوكرانيا عام 2014 من خلال
مجموعه عمليات خاصه شارك بودانوف في تبادل
الاسرى وشغل منصب رئيس هيئه تنسيق التعامل
مع اسرى الحرب كما كان عضوا في الوفد
الاوكراني بمحادثات انهاء الحصار الروسي
للبحر الاسود
[موسيقى]
تعمل روسيا حاليا على تطوير اول طائره
مسيره مزوده بجهاز تصوير حراري محليه
الصنع
والتي تستخدم في منطقه العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه وصممت هذه الطائرات الصغيره
المسيره للاستطلاع وتعديل نيران المدفعيه
وتتمثل مهمتها الرئيسيه بتحديد الاجسام
التي لها توقيع حراري مختلف عن البيئه مثل
المركبات والاشخاص على مسافه تصل الى 400
متر فيما مده رحلتها تصل الى خمس واربعين
دقيقه ويصل ارتفاعها الى ثلاثه كيلومترات
اما خصوصيتها فتكمن في قدرتها على حمل
محطات الكترونيه بصريه متعدده القنوات
وارسال صوره الى المشغل في الوقت الفعلي
تضاؤلوا مخزونات روسيا العسكريه بسبب
تدمير او فقدان الياتها في ساحه المعركه
الاوكرانيه اوجد الحاجه للارتجال فروسيا
وروسيا التي تمتلك ثاني اكبر جيش في
العالم تتجه نحو طرق بدائيه لتهجين
الاسلحه وتعويض النقص وفق تقرير للدييل
صور نشرتها الصحيفه البريطانيه تظهر اقدام
موسكو على لحم او تركيب الابراج البحريه
القديمه على سطح عربات مدرعه اقدم لصنع
دبابات بدائيه البرج البحري مشاهدينا مضاد
لطائرات عيار 25 ملي مترا تم تركيبه على
مركبه قتاليه وهي تو ام 3 برمائيه اي ام
تي ال بي من الحقبه السوفييتيه هذه
المركبات الهجينه ذات تصميم الهندسيه
السيء وفق وصف بعض الخبراء العسكريين
لديها هدفين اولهما محاوله اسقاط سيارات
الاوكرانيه اما ثاني هما فارسال هذه
المدرعات الى جزء اكثر هدوءا من خط
المواجهه حتى تتمكن طبعا القوات الروسيه
من نقل تكنولوجيا افضل الى المعارك
الرئيسيه هنا مسؤول عسكري بريطاني سابق
اكد ان مركبات مماثله شوهدت فقط بيد تنظيم
داعش لتكييفها في سوريا وحذر من ان قيام
جيش بضخامه الجيش الروسي بجامع معدات مثل
الجماعات الارهابيه يؤكد هنا مجددا خطوره
الوضع الروسي في اوكرانيا علما بان احاطه
استخباراتي بريطانيه اشارت الى اخراج
روسيا 800 دبابه عمرها يزيد عن 60 عاما من
مخازنها كما رجحت استبدال دبابات الحرس
الاول والتي يفترض انها قوه الدبابات
الاولى في روسيا بدبابات
مضيفه ان القياده العسكريه ترسل مقاتلين
مسلحين بمعاون ومجارف فقط لجبه ات القتال
[موسيقى]
اصدر وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه تقريرها
السنويه الخاص بتقييم المخاطر في العالم
والذي اشارتي الى ما وصفته بالسنوات
القادمه الحرجه بسبب روسيا والصين وانا
موسكو ستواصلان تهديد العالم وقال تقرير
ان روسيا ستظل تهديد الاكبر للدول الاخرى
في العالم وستستمر بمحاولاتها للتاثير على
الانتخابات الامريكيه وفيما يتعلق بالصين
اشار تقرير الاستخبارات الى ان بكين ستطور
من قدراتها لمواجهه الولايات المتحده
وبشان ايران وتهديداتها تحدثت التقرير عن
مواصله طهران تهديد مصالح واشنطن مضيفا ان
ايران ستكون مصدرا للاضطرابات من خلال
ميليشياتها واشار تقرير الاستخبارات
الامريكيه الى ان ايران لم تاخذ خطوات
واضحه لبناء القنبله النوويه
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من واشنطن مراسل
العربيه يعني اعاده ضبط الخطاب الامريكي
الذي هو طبعا متوازن وثابت بموضوع التصدي
لايران ولكن بهذه الفتره بالذات مع كل ما
يواجهه النظام ماذا يعني من هناك من
الولايات المتحده
يعني ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وضعت
ايران على مستوىنا عالم من الخطوره على
المصالح وعلى الاشخاص الامريكيين ووضعتها
الى جانب روسيا والصين وكوريا الشماليه
اللافت جدا في تقدير الاستخبارات هذه
السنه هو ان التقرير تحدث على ان ايران
تشكل مخاطر على الامريكيين وعلى المصالح
الامريكيه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وايضا
على اراضي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
النص جاء هذا التحذير من ان ايران سوف
تستعمل شبكات للعمل على اراضي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وتكون هذه الشبكات هي
شبكات عميله ومواليه لها بحد ما اذكر لم
تاتي الاستخبارات الامريكيه على ذكر هذا
الموضوع اقله ليس بهذا الوضوح خلال
السنوات العشره الماضيه
يعني ايضا بموازاه هذا الموقف الامريكي
هناك تصعيد اسرائيلي
على الاراضي السوريه عبر قصف واستهداف كل
الاسلحه والمعدات والميليشيات الايرانيه
بسوريا ايضا كيف تقرا الاوساط الامريكيه
هذا التصعيد بوسط يعني هذا الخطاب المتشدد
مجددا بوجه النظام الايراني
اعتبرت الاستخبارات الامريكيه في هذا
التقرير السنوي ان هناك خطران من قبل
ايران في منطقه الشرق الاوسط الخطر الاول
هو توزيع الاسلحه الصغيره والمسيرات
والصواريخ من قبل ايران على الميليشيات
ونشر هذه الاسلحه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وبالتالي هي تهديد مباشر لامن اسرائيل
اعتبرت ايضا الاستخبارات ان وجود
الميليشيات هو تهديد للامن وللاضطراب
بالنسبه لهذه الدول المنتشره في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تعتبر اولا ان هذه جزء من المخاطر وزير
الدفاع الامريكيه موجود في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط للعمل مع الحلفاء والشركاء لمواجهه
هذه المخاطر وهذه نقله شبه نوعيه خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه بالنسبه لتحديد الخطر
الايراني يعني ايضا بتحديد الخطر الايراني
ومواجهه التمدد الايراني وزير الدفاع كان
بزيارته الى العراق موضوع العراق وتمدد
الايراني من البوابه العراقيه التي تعتبر
تهديد لامن المنطقه باكمله وايضا كيف يقرا
التقرير
التقرير لم يتحدث كثيرا عن كيف تواجه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذه المخاطر
بل تتحدث على ان هناك مخاطر من قبل
الميليشيات المواليه لايران للجنود
الامريكيين المنتشرين على الاراضي
العراقيه وايضا على امن واستقرار العراق
بالعوده الى زياره وزير الدفاع الامريكي
شدد كثيرا على التعامل والعمل مع الحكومه
العراقيه والقوات العراقيه النظاميه
لمواجهه خطر داعش لكنه لم يتحدث كثيرا
اقله علنا على المواجهه هذه المخاطر
الايرانيه على اراضي العراق ولكن بالتقدير
العام لدى الامريكيين العراق هو الارض
الاساسيه
على ما يبدو نحن لا نرى الكثير من التقدم
بالنسبه للامريكيين شكرا لك
قال رئيس المخابرات الدفاعيه الامريكيه ان
تنظيم القاعده لا يشكل تهديدا للولايات
المتحده في الوقت الحالي مشيرا الى انه
يحاول النجا الا انه حذر من خطر داعش في
افغانستان
تقلصت قدرتنا على معرفه ما يحدث في
افغانستان منذ سقوط الحكومه لكن لا تزال
لدينا بعض القدره على ذلك وبناء على ما
نعرفه بشان تهديد القاعده هم يحاولون
النجاح ولا خطط لديهم للهجوم على الغرب
قريبا نعتقد ان تنظيم داعش هناك يشكل
تهديدا اكبر هم يتعرضون للهجوم من نظام
طالبان الان وهي مساله وقت قبل ان يكون
لديه القدره على مهاجمتنا
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
بيان فرنسي الماني بريطاني يحذر من اقتراب
ايران من السلاح النووي ويشدد على العواقب
الوحيمه التي تنتظر طهران
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تزامنا مع يوم المراه
العالميه عقوبات جديده فرضتها الولايات
المتحده على اثنين من كبار مسؤولي السجون
الايرانيين بسبب انتهاكات خطيره لحقوق
الانسان والنساء فيما خرجت النساء
الايرانيات في مظاهرات تهدد بنظام
الايراني وممارساته القمعيه ضد النساء
خاصه في ظل حالات تسميم الطالبات في
المدارس والجامعات الايرانيه
لتلقي المعارضه او تلقي المعارضه
الايرانيه تهمه على النظام
[موسيقى]
انتفاضه بدات بصوت النسائي وكانت النساء
اولى ضحاياها مقتلوا مهسا اميني كان شراره
التظاهرات في ايران واستمرت الحركه
الشعبيه في البلاد لتكون المراه متصدره
المشهد
تزامنا مع يوم المراه العالمي وتلبيه
لدعوه الناشطات النسويات اتجهت نساء ايران
الى الشوارع منددات بممارسات النظام
القمعيه بحق المراه على وجه التحديد
رقم محاولات النساء في ايران تحصيل حقوقهن
بهدف الحريه لم يستطعنا حتى الان تحقيق
ذلك السبب يعود الى ممارسه النظام
الايراني وقوانينه التي تقمع النساء
لم تغب حوادث وتسميم الطالبات في ايران عن
اللافتات بعد الجدل الذي اثرته تلك
الحوادث واختلاف الروايات حولها فمن جهه
المعرضه الايرانيه تتهم النظام بتلك
الممارسات وسط مطالبات دوليه بالتحقيق
فيها بينما يصر النظام الايراني على روايه
المؤامره وانخراط متظاهرين في تصميم
الطالبات
عمليات التسمم المستمره منذ ثلاثه اشهر لم
تترك اي مجال للشك في انها منظمه ويتم
تنفيذ هذه الجريمه حسب الاوامر خامنئي
ينتقموا من فتيات ايران اللواتي لعبن دورا
حاسما في الانتفاضه الاخيره ويريد ترهيبهن
قمع وقتل وتعذيب وتسميم ممارسات ليست
غريبه عن النظام الايراني بحق شعبه عامه
والنساء خاصه اسماء كثيره كانت ضحيه
ونداءات دوليه تطالب النظام بوقف العنف
ومحاسبته على تلك الانتهاكات الى عمر
العربيه
وفي افغانستان الامر لم يختلف كثيرا حيث
خرجت سيدات للتظاهر في اليوم العالمي
تمديدا بقمع حكومه طالبان التي تولت
السلطه في اغسطس عام 2021 حيث فرضت منذ
ذلك الحين تدابير صارمه على السيدات من
بينها حظر تعليم الفتيات كما منعوا النساء
من العمل في المنظمات غير الحكوميه
والدوليه من جانبها قالت الامم المتحده
اليوم ان افغانستان تحولت عقب سيلاء طالبا
على السلطه الى الدوله الاكثر قمعا للنساء
والفتيات
[موسيقى]
بدوره قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في
بيان بمناسبه يوم المراه العالمي ان حقوق
المراه تتعرض للهجوم في افغانستان وايران
واضافت جو بايدن المراه في افغانستان
وايران تتعرض للهجوم بشكل يعيق المجتمعات
ونظام الايراني ويقمع بشكل وحشى اصوات
النساء
وفي خبر يخص ايران ايضا هددت الدول
الاوروبيه ثلاث فرنسا والمانيا وبريطانيا
وايران من ان عدم تقديمها اجوبه مقنعه
للوكاله حول سبب العثور على اثار يورانيوم
مخصب بنسبه 84% بشكل سريع سيعرضها
للمحاسبه وقالت بان ردها حتى الان غير
مقنع وهذا واكد دبلوماسيون غربيون للعربيه
ان الدول الغربيه قد تدعو لاجتماع طارق
للوكاله خلال الاسابيع القليله المقبله
وتطرح مشروع قرار يدين ايران في حال وجدت
ان ايران لا تتعاون بجديه مع الوكاله
النقاشات داخل قاعه مجلس المحافظين هنا
حول ايران طغت عليها المخاوف من اثار
اليورانيوم العاليه التخصيب التي عثر
عليها مفتشون تابعون للوكاله في منشاه
فوردو الايرانيه والتي بلغت تقريبا اربعه
وثمانين بالمئه ولكن الدبلوماسيين
الغربيين هنا يقولون انهم يتمهلون
بالتصعيد لاعطاء ايران فرصه لشرح اسباب
العثور على اثار اليورانيوم العالي
التخصيب هذا الدبلوماسيون او الدول
الاوروبيه حذرت حتى ايران من ان عدم اعطاء
جواب لامين عام الوكاله الدوليه رافاييل
جروستي كما وعدت وبشكل سريع سيعرضها
للمحاسبه وقالت بان الرد الذي اعطته حتى
الان غير مقنعه
اسابيع قليله ستظهر ما اذا كانت ايران
ستفي بتعهداتها التي اطلقتها على رفايا
الجروس امين عام الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه هنا ام انها تماطل من جديد وهكذا
مماطله ستدفع بالدول الغربيه للدعوه
الاجتماع طارق لمجلس المحافظين كما اكد
لنا دبلوماسيون حتى قبل اجتماع المجلس
الدوري في يونيو المقبل وطرح مشروع قرار
جديد يدين ايران يكون الثالث خلال عام
واحد راغده برنامج العربيه
[موسيقى]
سبعه قتلى من بينهم ثلاثه افغاديين من
مليشيا لواء فاطميون سقطوا جرائم انفجار
مستودع للاسلحه تابع للمليشيات الايرانيه
في دير الزور لكن هذا الانفجار وقع بفعل
فاعل فغار جويا نفذتها مسيره والمسيره
امريكيه وبالتنسيق مع الجانب الاسرائيلي
وفقا لمصدر غربي اكد للعربيه هذا المستودع
بانه وفقا لما افاد به المرصد السوري
للعربيه هو لتجميع صواريخ ارض ارض قصيره
المدى استهدفتها مسيره امريكيه انطلقت من
احدى القواعد الامريكيه على الضفه الشرقيه
لنهر الفرات ودير الزور
[موسيقى]
في سياق الموازن قال وزير الخارجيه
التركيه مولود شاوج اوغلو خلال مؤتمر صحفي
مع نظيره الايراني في انقره ان مسار
استانا هو الاليه الوحيده قيد التفعيل
ولحل الخلافات مع سوريا وان روسيا عرضت
استضافه اجتماع تمهيديه تحضيرا للاجتماع
الرباعي بمشاركه ايران في موسكو الاسبوع
المقبل
مساره اسنانه هو الاليه الوحيده لحال
الخلافات مع سوريا وابلغنا روسيا ان لا
مشكله في مشاركه ايران بالاجتماعات نخطط
الان لعقد اجتماع بين وزراء الخارجيه
الاربعه روسيا عرضت استضافه اجتماع تمهيدي
تحضيرا للاجتماع الرباعي وسنرسل ممثلنا في
الخارجيه الى موسكو الاسبوع المقبل كما
ستحضر ايران الاجتماع ايضا
[موسيقى]
زلزال تركيا وسوريا لم يكن مدمرا للبشر
والبناء فقط بل قد تسبب بتدمير شعبيه
اردوغان وحزب العداله والتنميه في
الانتخابات فلو اجريت الانتخابات التركيه
قبل عام من الان او قبل الزلزال المدمر
لكانت فرصه فوز اردوغان مجددا بالرئاسه
اكبر لكن الوضع تغير الان وفقا لاستطلاعا
للرايب اجرته وكاله رويترز واخذت شهاده 30
ناجيا من الزلزال في كهرمان مرعش وادي
يامان وغازي عنتاب تشير الى تحول في
الولاء حتى بين من كانوا ذات يوم متعصبين
في تاييدهم لاردوغان الذي يدرك مشاهدينا
بشكل متزايد انه لا يمكن ان يضمن الاصوات
التي كانت مؤيده له سابقا اذ يتحدث
مسؤولون عن تسريع خطط اعاده البناء قبل
الانتخابات المقرره في مايو ايار والتي قد
تكون الاصعب خلال اكثر من عقدين اردوغان
في السلطات تراجع شعبيه اردوغان لا يعني
ارتفاع اسهم المعارضه فبحس فان غالبيه
المستطلعين يرون انه لا تفاؤل بالمعارضه
وانهم ليسوا بافضل حال من اردوغان وحزب
العداله والتنميه وفقا للاستطلاع طبعا كما
ان مسؤولون وسياسيون اتراك يرون في الوقت
نفسه ان الوقت ليس مناسبا لاجراء انتخابات
رئاسيه في تركيا بموعدها لان الناس متضرره
وما زالت تتالم بعد زلزال
[موسيقى]
حول التصعيد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه افاد
مراسل العربيه عن قيام الدبابات
الاسرائيليه باطلاق قذائف على مواقع رصد
ميدني تابعه لحماس قرب حدود قطاع غزه وذلك
بعد تفجير عبوه قرب احد المعابر الحدوديه
اثناء عمل دوريه عسكريه اسرائيليه في
تجريف منطقه فيما طالب الجيش الاسرائيلي
من المستوطنين عدم دخول الاراضي المحاذيه
للحدود مع قطاع غزه خشيه من عمليات قص
هذا وعمل اضراب العام مختلف مدن الضفه
الغربيه حدادا على ضحايا الهجوم
الاسرائيليه على مخيم جنين والذي اسفر عن
مقتل سته فلسطينيين واصابه اخرين وكانت
القوى الوطنيه قد دعت لاضراب شامل والخروج
في تظاهرات تمديدا بالهجمات الاسرائيليه
المتواليه على المدن الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
بدورها اعربه الخارجيه السعوديه عن ادانه
واستنكار المملكه للاقتحام القوات
الاسرائيليه مخيم جنين في الضفه الغربيه
ما ادى لسقوط ضحايا واصابه اخرين هذا
واكدت الخارجيه رفض المملكه العربيه
السعوديه التام لما تقوم به القوات
الاسرائيليه من انتهاكات خطيره
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
بها فريلوسوفو
مشروع قانون الهجره غير النظاميه بالعادل
والامم المتحده ترد يعني انهاء حق اللجوء
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في اجتماع
وزراء الخارجيه العرب في القاهره دعا وزير
الخارجيه المصريه الى وقف التدخلات
الخارجيه وخروج المرتزقه من ليبيا
وبهذه المناسبه ان مصر تعيد التاكيد على
دعمها الكامل لمسار الحل الليبي الليبي
ورفضها لاي املاءات خارجيه على الاشقاء
الليبيين او تجاوز لدوره المؤسسات الليبيه
وفقا لمرجعيه اتفاق الصخيرات وتدعو جميع
الاطراف المنخرطه في الازمه الليبيه في
الالتزام بهذه الاسس والمحددات التي لا
بديل عنها وترى ان المحاولات لاختلاق
الاليات المستحدثه انما الغرض منها ارباك
المشهد من اجل تكريس الوضع القائم
كما تشدد على ضروره خروج جميع القوات
الاجنبيه والمقاتلين الاجانب والمرتزقه من
ليبيا في مدى زمني محدد وحلل الميليشيات
ودعم مهمه لجنه خمسه زائد خمسه العسكريه
المشتركه ذات الصله
وفي الشان اللي به ايضا لقاء بين رئيس
الحكومه الليبيه عبد الحميد الدبابه مع
المبعوثه الامريكي لليبيا بحسب طرفان في
جهود الانتخابات خلال العام الحالي بيان
حكومه الذبابه اكد دعمه لجهود اجراء
الانتخابات من قبل المبعوث الاممي عبد
الله باتيني السفاره الامريكيه في ليبيا
نقلت عن المبعوثه الاممي بان مبادره
باتيره تستحق الدعم من كافه الاطراف
[موسيقى]
الى بريطانيا وبالتحديد حول ملف الهجره
غير الشرعيه حيث اعتبرت الامم المتحده ان
مشروع القانون الذي طرحته حكومه سوناك ضد
الهجره غير القانونيه يعني انهاء حق
اللجوء وقالت المفوضيه الساميه للامم
المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين في بيان على ان
القانون سيرقى في حال اقراره الى حد انهاء
حق اللجوء ما سيحرم الواصلين بشكل غير
قانوني الى المملكه المتحده من الحق في
طلب الحمايه الممنوحه للاجئين مشدده على
انه سيكون انتهاكا واضحا للاتفاقيه الخاصه
بوضع اللاجئين
نحن لا نخالف القانون ولم يقل اي ممثل
حكومي اننا نخرق القانون في الواقع بينا
اعتقادنا باننا نمتثل لجميع التزاماتنا
الدوليه على سبيل المثال اتفاقيه اللاجئين
والاتفاقيه الاوروبيه لحقوق الانسان
والاتفاقيات الاخرى التي نخضع لها المهم
هنا هو اننا بحاجه الى اتخاذ اجراءات
رحيمه ولكنها ضروريه وعادله الان لان هناك
اشخاصا يموتون لمحاوله الوصول الى هنا فهم
يخالفون قوانيننا ويستغلون كرم الشعب
البريطاني ونحن الان بحاجه الى ضمان ردعهم
عن فعل ذلك نحن بحاجه لكسر نموذج عصابات
تهريب البشر نحن بحاجه الى منع الناس من
القيام بهذه الرحله في المقام الاول اذا
كانوا يريدون المجيء الى المملكه المتحده
فعليهم اختيار المجيء الى هنا عبر طرق
امنه وقانونيه
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا مراسلين العربيه
فادده وعبد وعروب عبد الحق للحديث عن يعني
تداعيات هذا الملف سابدا معك عروب هذا
مشروع القانون هذا يعني على ماذا ينص كيف
سيتم تطبيقه وماذا سيحل باللاجئين عندما
يطبق
مرحبا ليال يعني طبعا بالنسبه لمشروع
القرار هذا كان له تاثير كبير على
اللاجئين
المتواجدين هنا في مدينه دوفر نحن الان في
هذه المدينه وهي النقطه الحدوديه التي
عاده ما يصل اليها اللاجئون من فرنسا في
رحله يعني مدتها حوالي الساعه وال40 دقيقه
عبر قوارب تسمى بقوارب الموت الى هذه
المدينه ومن ثم يتم يعني اخذهم الى مراكز
احتجاز وكنا في احد يعني مراكز الاحتجاز
اليوم هذا الصباح والتقينا بعدد من
اللاجئين ويمكن القول بان الخوف والقلق
يطغى على مشاعر هؤلاء اللاجئين حتى يعني
احد اللاجئين قال لي بانه يفضل الانتحار
يعني على ان يتم ترحيله من هذه من هذا
الميلاد اما بالنسبه لمشروع القرار وكيفيه
تطبيقه والجدل حوله هذه هي المعضله
الاساسيه مشروع القرار هذا يعني يواجه ان
معضله قانونيه ومعضله اخلاقيه قانونيه
وذلك لان بريطانيا كما نعلم سبق وان اصدرت
يعني مشروع قرار مثل هذا العام الماضي
مثلا بترحيلهم الى رواندا وفاشل هذا
القرار بسبب يعني بعض العقبات القانونيه
سواء من المحكمه المحكمه الاوروبيه او
بشكل يعني او من الناحيه الانسانيه ايضا
فكيفيه تطبيق هذا مشروع القرار هذا وكيفيه
تجنب بريطانيا مثلا الاتفاقيات الامم
المتحده الخاصه باللاجئين او المعاهدات
حقوق الانسان المتعلقه باوروبا كيف ستتجنب
بريطانيا هذه انتهاك هذه الاتفاقيات هو
الامر الذي لابد يعني منه كيف سيتم
التعامل معه يعني نعم ساعود اليك ولكن
اسمحي لي ان انتقل الى الزميل فادي الدهوك
فادي كيف هي الصوره من هناك وطبعا هناك
يعني معضله اساسيه ان كان قانونيه او او
حتى يعني باماكن تواجدهم كيف هي الصوره من
عندك
اهلا ليال الاوضاع المهاجرين هنا صعبه جدا
في مدينه كاليه الحدوديه نحن هنا في احد
المواقع التي كان فيه عدد كبير من الخيام
هنا جاءت الشرطه واخذت كل الخيام من هؤلاء
المهاجرين ووضعت صخورا ضخمه هنا كما
ترونها على الكاميرا لكي تمنعهم من اعاده
التموضع هنا هم يتنقلون بين الغابات
يختبئون في الغابات هربا من الشرطه كي لا
تلقي القبض عليهم لان هناك عدد كبير منهم
صدر بحقهم اوامر ترحيل من فرنسا بالاضافه
الى ان هناك اخرين
جاؤوا الى فرنسا ولا تعلم السلطات بوجودهم
كانوا في ايطاليا على سبيل المثال او في
اسبانيا او حتى في ليبيا جاؤوا بهدف
العبور الى بريطانيا من هذه النقطه من هنا
على الجهه الاخرى هناك ايضا عدد من
المهاجرين الذين يختبئون تحت احد الجسور
طبعا
طلبوا منا الا نقترب اكثر الى تلك المنطقه
كي لا نلفت انتباه الشرطه اليهم كما ترون
يشعلون النار يشعلون كل شيء يجدونه لكي
يتدفقوا درجه الحراره الاحساس الحقيقي
بدرجه الحراره اليوم هذه الليله هو ست
درجات تحت الصفر والان بدات
الثلوج بالهطول اوضاعهم صعبه جدا وهم
يحاولون العبور الى بريطانيا عبر القوارب
او عبر البر عن طريق الشاحنات لكن هذه
الرحلات محفوفه بالمخاطر بشكل كبير لان
السلطات الفرنسيه
مراقبتهم من اي الدول تحديدا ما التقيت
بهم هنا
الل او المهاجرين
هذه المجموعه التي ترونها على الكاميرا هم
من سوريا هناك تقريبا حوالي العشره اشخاص
ينامون في تلك المنطقه تحت الجسر يشعلون
النيران لكي يتدفقوا لكن ايضا هناك
مهاجرين من جنسيات عديده مختلفه هناك من
جنسيات افريقيه هناك مهاجرين من مصر من
ليبيا من جنسيات عديده جدا كلهم ياتون الى
مناطق متفرقه هنا في مدينه كاليه لكي
يحاولوا العبور الى بريطانيا هناك عدد
كبير من الجمعيات التي تحاول مساعدتهم لكن
السلطات تضيق الخناق على عمل هذه الجمعيات
من خلال منعها من تقديم المساعده احيانا
ومنذ بدايه هذا الشهر الشرطه قامت بوضع
اسلاك شائكه على المناطق التي يتواجد فيها
المهاجرون لكي يمنعوا هذه المنظمات من
تقديم المساعده اليهم والدخول الى المناطق
التي يختبئ فيها فادي اسمح لي ان اعود الى
عروب عروب يعني عندما يقول صنعك بان وقف
القوارب سيكون مره واحده والى الابد كيف
يعني مع الاعتراض الدولي الموجود كيف
ستواجه بريطانيا الاعتراض الامم الواضح
حول هذه الخطوه
يعني يبدو ان هناك اصرار من الحكومه
البريطانيه سواء من خلال ما سمعناه من
وزيره الداخليه البريطانيه او من خلال ما
سمعناه من رئيس الحكومه البريطانيه الذين
قالوا بانهم سيعملون على مواجهه جميع
التحديات سواء القانونيه او القضائيه التي
ستمنع مثل هكذا وبالتالي هناك يبدو اصرار
من الحكومه على مواجهه وتمرير مثل هذا
المشروع مثل هذا مثل هذا القانون ولكن كما
نعلم بانه كاي مشروع قانون يعني يصدر في
بريطانيا لابد له من السير في المسار يعني
المخصص لمثل هكذا مشاريع لابد لمجلس
العموم ان يستمع الى يعني مشروع القرار
هذا ومن ثم من بعد تمريره يتم الاستماع له
في مجلس اللوردات وبالتالي هناك يعني
ستكون هناك اليه لتطبيق مشروع القرار هذا
ولكن ما يتيحه مشروع القرار هذا بالنسبه
لوزيره الداخليه يمنحها صلاحيات لي يعني
بعض القرارات بشان اللاجئين القادمين سواء
من خلال يعني اهم نقطه هي وضع هؤلاء
اللاجئين خارج نظام اللجوء اي يعني بانهم
يعني ما يرحلون خلال فتره معينه سواء الى
بلدانهم اذا كانت امنه او الى بلد ثالث
مثل رواندا كما كانت الاتفاقيه او انهم
مثلا يعني يمنعون من الدخول الى المملكه
المتحده مدى الحياه او يعني اتخاذ المسار
الطبيعي لنا الحصول على الاوراق الثبوتيه
والرسميه التي تمنحهم الجنسيه وتمنحهم
وبالتالي اجراءات صارمه فادي باختصار لو
سمحت كيف يتم التنسيق بين السلطات
الفرنسيه والبريطانيه بهذا الملف بالنقاط
التي يعني جلت بها واطلعت فيها على سير
الامور
ليال هناك تفاهمات فرنسيه بريطانيه تتعلق
بالدرجه الاولى بان تكثف فرنسا من جانبها
الدوريات الحدوديه في البحر وايضا في البر
هناك عدد كبير من طائرات الاستطلاع
للمراقبه تخرج وتجوب الاجواء لكي تراقب
حركه القوارب وتمنعها من العبور الى
بريطانيا هناك عدد كبير ايضا من رجال
الشرطه الذين ينتشرون ويقومون بتسير
دوريات كل الليل لمحاوله معرفه من اين
تخرج هذه القوارب والقاء القبض على هؤلاء
اللاجئين وحتى المهربين الذين ينقلونهم
شكرا لكما فادي الدهوك حدثنا من كاليه
وعروب عبد الحق من دوفر على هذه الرسائل
[موسيقى]
قالت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه ماونين قالت ان الصين تعارض بحزم
اي شكل من اشكال التبادلات الرسميه بين
الولايات المتحده وتايوان وترفض بشده
زياره رئيس القوه الانفصاليه للاستقلال
والاستقلال التايوان للولايات المتحده باي
اسم ولاي سبب
الصين قلقه للغايه بشان المعلومات عن
العبور المزمعي لزعيم تايوان
والاجتماع مع رئيس مجلس النواب كيفن
مكاردي في الولايات المتحده لقد قدمنا
شكاوى رسميه الى الولايات المتحده
وحثثناها على تقديم توضيحات تعارض الصين
بحزم اي شكل من اشكال التبادلات الرسميه
بين الولايات المتحده وتايوان وترفض بشده
زياره رئيس القوه الانفصاليه لاستقلال
تايوان للولايات المتحده باي اسم ولاي سبب
نعارض بحزم اي اتصال بين الولايات المتحده
والقوه الانفصاليه لاستقلال تايوان ينتهك
مبدا الصين الواحده
في محاوله لقطع يد التكنولوجيا الصينيه
المتغلله في الاجواء الامريكيه او على
الاقل تكبيلها وابقائها تحت النظر رحب
البيت الابيض باقتراح قانون من شانه ان
يمكن الولايات المتحده من حظر تطبيق تيك
توك للفيديوهات القصيره المملوك لشركه
صينيه حيث اكد مستشار الامن القومي جيك
سوليفان اهميه مشروع القانون الهاتف لمنع
حكومات اجنبيه من استغلال خدمات تكنولوجيه
ودرء المخاطر الامنيه المرافقه المتحدثه
باسم تيك توك وصفت من جهتها اي حظ اي حظر
امريكي بالحظر على تصدير الثقافه والقيم
الامريكيه الى اكثر من مليار شخص يستخدمون
التطبيق حول العالم لكن الرد المباشر اتمن
تيك توك كما وصف وجاء في خانه المنافسه
الشديده لاحدى الخدمات الامريكيه الرائده
بمجال الفيديوهات وهي يوتيوب حيث اضافت
ميزه جديده
وهي
ميزات سيريز تتمثل باتاحه نشر فيديوهات
اطول تصل مدتها الى 20 دقيقه بعدما كانت
محدوده بعشر دقائق فقط متيحا ومتيحه هنا
لصناع المحتوى مجالا جديدا لكسب المال
لمنافسه يوتيوب تيك توك يتيح لمستخدمه
انتاج مقاطع مصوره تصل مدتها الى 20 دقيقه
واذا تجاوز الفيديو هذه المده فسيكون
بمقابل مادي فاتحا بذلك بابا جديدا
لمستخدمه لكسب المال اطول مده يسمح بها
تيك توك للمقاطع المصوره حاليا هي 10
دقائق لكن بعد تفعيل خدمته الجديده سيريز
بامكان صناع المحتوى بث 80 مقطعا مصورا
مده كل منها 20 دقيقه
يامل تيك توك بمنافسه يوتيوب عملاق جوجل
حيث يتيح الفرصه لمستخدمي لتقديم محتوى
مثل عرض جداول البيانات والتمارين البدنيه
ووصفات الطعام
بلغ عدد مستخدمي تيك توك مليار مستخدم
ناشط شهريا في سبتمبر 2021
قال كريس
درالي ان الصين قادره على استخدام تيك توك
لتحكم في اجهزه مستخدمي جاء ذلك خلال رده
على اسئله السيناتور ماركو روبيو خلال
جلسه استماع امام الكونغرس
انضم الينا مشاهدي
الشبكات استاذ احمد يعني سابدا بالسؤال
البديهي عندما نتحدث عن تطبيق بالولايات
المتحده يتابعه اكثر من مليار
ومئه مليون اتحدث عن الجيل الشاب هل
بالسهل يعني حضروا نهائيا عن هذا الجيل
حظر نهائيا صعب جدا لانه بعض النواب وبعض
الاعضاء الكونسترددين بسبب انه كثير من
الناس اللي صوتوا لهم خايفه انهم يغيروا
رايهم بعد ما يكون منع كامل لهذا التطبيق
وبالتالي يعني نحن نتحدث عن ماذا عن منع
جزئي ماذا ينفع
الفكره الاساسيه من القانون هذا الان اللي
هو الان لسه في الكونغرس بيوصل للرئيس انه
ما يمنعوا تطبيق بعينه يتكلموا على عمليه
منع خدمات والمنع ما حيجي من الرئيس حيجي
من وزيره التجاره او وزير التجاره القادم
وهو اللي يكتب التوصيات ويرسلها للرئيس
والرئيس بعدين يمنع هذه الخدمات هو ما
يتكلموا على التطبيق بعينه طيب عندما يمنع
الخدمات ماذا يعني ذلك على مستخدمين تيك
توك بالولايات المتحده
هذه معناها انه حتصير عمليه يعني حصار
للتطبيق نفسه تضييق طلب معلومات الان رئيس
الشركه الصينيه او رئيس الصيني لشركه تيك
توك في الكونغرس يوم 23 مارس على اساس انه
يسالوه عن ايش طبيعه هذا التطبيق وكيف
الحكومه الصينيه بتحصل على المعلومات
فهيحصل عليها تضييق كبير الى درجه انه ما
تقدر تسوي اي شغل في امريكا طيب الناحيه
الاخرى من هذا الموضوع هي ناحيه المنافسه
بين تيك توك ويوتيوب بعد يعني الميزه التي
اطافها تيك توك الى اي مدى ايضا ممكن يعني
ان تدفع اكثر الى التعجيل بهذا القرار
جماعه يوتيوب وجماعه فيسبوك والشركات
الامريكيه يعني الان بتحتفل بالقانون هذا
لانه هذا حيلغي واحد من اكبر المنافسين
لهم في السوق فمن ناحيتهم هم بيدفعوا فيها
وهذا سبب انك تشوف انه في اتفاق بين
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين على انه هذه
القانون يتم تطبيقه هذا السبب انه حصل
اتفاق لانه لمصلحه الشركات الامريكيه هذه
المصلحه هل ممكن ان تدفع شركات الامريكيه
لخلق تطبيق مشابه
لتيك توك بما انه يعني سيتم تضييق الخناق
عليه
سؤال جيد جدا
المنافسه دائما جيده للابداع يعني وانتاج
التطبيقات الجيده
فكون انه الان عرفوا على انه الناس رغبتهم
في الشيء هذا فهم هيعملوا تطبيقات تكون
تتعامل مثل فيسبوك عنده ريلز اللي هو مثيل
لتكتاكو ونفس الطريقه يعني اتكلم على
يوتيوب يحاول يعمل شورت على اساس انه
ينافس لكن الفرق بينهم وبين تيك توك
بيستخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي حتى يفهم نفسيه
وعقليه المستخدم
ساسال عن ايلون ماسك الذي دائما ما يقتنص
الفرص عندما يكون هناك فرصه وهو تحدث عن
موضوع تيك توك قبل وكان يريد يعني طرح شيء
هل ممكن ان يذهب نحو شيء منافس لهذا
التطبيق
هو الان مرطان باللي فيه على كلامنا يعني
مع تويتر لانه ما قدر يقنع
المستثمرين من ناحيه واصحاب الشركات انهم
يعملون اعلانات في تويتر بسبب تصرفات
غريبه اخرها التصرف الاخير معه واحد من
الموظفين اللي عنده اعاقه اعاقه جسديه
وكان في مشاكل فيها فهو يعني انا ما
استغرب على انه ممكن يعني في المستقبل
لانه هو خطته يخلي تويتر يسمونه سوبر اب
اللي هو يشمل كل شيء فهو ممكن ممكن يدخل
حاجه زي كذا
شكرا لك استاذ دكتور احمد بن نافع استاذ
الهندسه وامن الشبكات في على هذه المداخله
والتوضيح
[موسيقى]
اطلقت الشرطه اليونانيه الغاز المسيل
للدموع على متظاهرين القوا قنابل حارقه
خارج مبنى البرلمان في اثينا خلال مظاهره
حاشده احتجاجا على حادثه القطار المميت
الذي وقع الاسبوع الماضي
[موسيقى]
دراسه جديده نشرت في مجلات
تؤكد وتقدم رؤى جديده وتحضيرات حول مدى
الضرر الذي يمكن ان يحدث ارتفاع منسوب
مياه البحار على ملايين الاشخاص وتحديدا
في المدن الاسيويه الكبرى
علماء يتوقعون ارتفاع منسوب مياه البحر
خلال القرنين المقبلين وتحديدا في المدن
الاسيويه الكبرى
الدراسه تضمنت تاثير تغير المناخ
والتقلبات الطبيعيه للمحيطات ما قد يجعل
المياه تغمر اجزاء واسعه من اكبر المدن
الاسيويه بحلول عام 2100
وذلك بسبب استمرار ارتفاع مستويات سطح
البحر
وارتفاع درجات حراره المحيطات والمستويات
غير المسبوقه من ذوبان الجليد اكثر من 50
شخص سيتاثرون بالارتفاع المتوقع في مستوى
سطح البحر
وما يقرب من ثلاثين مليون منهم في الهند
[موسيقى]
ختام التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العنا
وينز
مصير مجهول لينتظر اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
موسكو ترفض التنازل وجوتيرج يدعو لتمديد
الصفقه
عقوبات امريكيه على مسؤولين كبيرين في
السجون الايرانيه
لانتهاكهم حقوق الانسان
مصادر غربيه للعربيه غارت دير الزور
استهدفت اسلحه ايرانيه ونفذتها الولايات
المتحده بالتنسيق مع اسرائيل
تداعيات الزلزال تهدد شعبيه اردوغان في
الانتخابات وناجونه يقولون المعارضه ليست
بافضل
مشاهدينا التاسع انتهت لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل ليله والان الى 360
والزميله ميسون نوهد ميسون مساء الخير
ومذا لديك مساء الخير ليان اليوم سنتحدث
عن ان واشنطن ما زالت تعتبر روسيا والصين
مصدر تهديد العلم ايضا سنتحدث عن موضوع
تفجير نورد ستريم وهناك تقرير تتحدث بانه
حصل باياد اوكرانيه فضلا طبعا عن يوم
المراه العالمي ووضع المراه في بعض
البلدان التي تعاني من هذه لحقوقها طبعا
لابد الا ان نعيد كل نساء العالم اليوم
شكرا